Prof: Welcome back.
And what I want to do this
morning is to be cognizant of
the fact that you have,
as you all know,
the hour exam later this week.
It's in a different format,
and I've written to you about
that.
Because of that,
what I thought would be useful
to do this morning would be to
have something of a review
session,
in which we make explicit some
of the ways in which it's useful
to think about epidemic
diseases,
and in which we go over some of
the terrain that we've covered
thus far in the semester.
At the same time,
I want to talk about--
introduce a new and important
disease,
which is syphilis,
and provide a bit of background
for the book that you're reading
this week,
which is Allan Brandt's No
Magic Bullet.
And you'll be wanting to know,
well where did syphilis come
from, what's the historical
background?
So, I'm going to try to
introduce that,
while going over some of the
issues that we've already
presented.
You'll find a lot that's
already familiar this morning,
as we go back in time,
covering major issues that
we've dealt with.
And I hope, at the same time,
to be introducing something
new, which is syphilis.
So, we'll look at the period
we've covered in the course,
through the lens of syphilis.
That's the direction in which
we're headed.
Now, in order to talk about a
variety of epidemic diseases and
their impact,
we ought to have some
comparative questions that we
make explicit.
That is, what is it that we
need to know about each of the
diseases that we're talking
about?
What are the crucial aspects
that make it a transformative
force or not?
What are the historical
variables?
I have a sort of suggestion of
maybe ten major questions that
we ought to be thinking about
with regard to each of the
diseases that we examine
throughout the semester.
A first one is--these
questions, by the way,
are not canonical.
I don't mean that you shouldn't
be asking other questions as
well, and indeed I hope you
will.
But I think we should know at
least the answers to these ten
questions and then build on that
as a foundation.
The first major question,
for any of the diseases we're
talking about,
was what's the total mortality
and morbidity that's caused by
the epidemic in question?
The mortality,
the total numbers of deaths.
Morbidity, the total number of
cases.
That's an important factor that
needs to be taken into account
in assessing the impact of the
epidemic.
A second question has to do
with a term we introduced long
ago, a phrase,
which was the case fatality
rate.
And a related question with
that is,
is there an effective therapy
or means of prevention,
or instead does a society
experience the disease in
feeling itself to be helpless,
and physicians feeling the same?
The case fatality rate is--we
could call it the kill rate of a
disease, the percentage of cases
that terminate in death.
And we know that,
for example,
in dealing with plague,
one of the features of it--and
Asiatic cholera as well--
was a very high case fatality
rate,
of plague, fifty to eighty
percent,
cholera, something like fifty
percent.
At the other extreme,
when we come to it,
we'll see that influenza has a
very high morbidity,
but quite a low case fatality
rate,
and that's related,
I think, to the impact that
that disease,
influenza, has on society,
which isn't associated with
such terror as say plague or
cholera.
That's an important variable,
the kill rate of the disease.
Another factor,
a third question we need to
ask, is what's the nature of the
symptoms of the infectious
disease in question?
Are they particularly painful?
Are they degrading,
according to the norms of the
time?
And we've seen,
for example,
in dealing with plague and
cholera that a major feature
about them was that their
symptoms were agonizing and
dehumanizing.
Clearly, as we turn to
syphilis, its symptoms also were
extremely important in the way
that the disease was
experienced.
Tuberculosis,
on the other hand--and we'll be
looking at that--
was seen, at the time,
to make its sufferers more
intelligent,
more romantic,
more beautiful in some sense,
at least in the first half of
the nineteenth century.
So, that--what is the nature of
the symptoms,
is a crucially important
question.
Another, fourth question,
that I hope you'll bear in mind
throughout the course,
and in your review for the
exercise this week,
is the question,
is this disease new,
or is it familiar to the
population?
Familiar diseases tend not to
be so terrifying.
The population is also likely
to have some degree of immunity
to the disease,
and the disease is likely,
or may have,
already mutated to become less
deadly.
Examples are the so-called
diseases of childhood,
like chickenpox,
mumps and measles;
normally relatively mild,
but in populations to which
they're newly introduced,
they can be devastating.
A fifth question has to do
with, what's the profile of the
victims of the disease?
Is this a disease that's an
affliction of the young and the
elderly;
that is, experienced as a more
normal course of a disease,
in accord with society's
expectations and past
experience?
Or does it instead strike down
particularly those who are in
the prime of life,
thereby no longer seeming
natural but as something
extraordinary in the experience
of the population?
And it also means that the
disease is likely to maximize
its economic and financial
impact, to be particularly
destabilizing to a community.
Cholera, in this regard,
for example,
was terrifying because of the
way in which it seemed to
afflict those who were the
bulwarks of families and of
communities.
A sixth question that's
important: what's the class
profile of the sufferers?
What sorts of people in society
are stricken with the
affliction?
Is this a disease of poverty,
such as cholera is usually
thought of?
Or is it an affliction that
strikes everyone,
without particular reference to
class or social and economic
status, like influenza or
syphilis, indeed?
A seventh important question is
what is the mode of transmission
of the disease?
Is it transmitted person to
person?
Is it transmitted by
contaminated food and water?
Are vectors involved?
Is it spread through the air by
droplets?
Is it spread by sexual contact?
And clearly,
I think we'll be arguing that
the mode of transmission is
really crucial,
and in sexually transmitted
diseases I think that that is
fairly self-evident and a very
important factor in the social
impact of those diseases.
An eighth important question is
whether the disease is fulminant
in its course,
or is it slow acting and a
wasting disease?
If we look, for example,
at cholera, one of the
features, and a striking one,
is that it was one of the most
fulminant of diseases.
It would strike down a
sufferer, and you could board a
train and die before you reached
your destination,
as the disease ran its course
that quickly through the human
body.
Or, on the other hand,
is the disease one that takes
years, perhaps even decades,
to run its course?
And an example of that,
of course, would be
tuberculosis or HIV-AIDS,
in our own time.
A ninth important question we
need always to bear in mind is
how is the disease understood by
the population that it's
infecting?
Is it seen as a punishment of
God?
Is it later on thought to be
something that comes from the
dangerous classes?
Or later on,
is it understood to be a
microbial infection?
And those ways in which the
disease is understood have
enormous impact on how the
population reacts to the
disease.
A tenth variable is what's the
duration of the epidemic?
Influenza, for example,
passes through a locality in a
matter of weeks,
normally.
Cholera or plague tend to have
epidemics that last for months.
And tuberculosis,
one might describe as an
epidemic in slow motion that
afflicts a community for a whole
century or more.
So, those are ten major
questions that I hope that
you'll be bearing in mind
throughout the course.
I think they'll help you in
dealing with the diseases in a
comparative manner,
and finding out and teasing out
why some diseases have an impact
of one kind,
and others are very different.
Well, this morning I'd like to
go through some of this material
again, in a review manner,
by looking at syphilis.
Why syphilis at this stage of
the course?
I think that it provides
background for No Magic
Bullet,
and it also helps us to look at
some of the material that we've
already covered,
and that you'll be writing
about in the next few days.
Well, first let's deal then
with the chronology,
and this helps us to step back
in time from the nineteenth
century;
to go back, indeed,
to the plague years.
Syphilis, in fact,
was contemporary in its onset
with plague,
and like plague,
at the time it was a new
disease that first struck
Europe,
in this case, in the late 1490s.
And we'll see that there's an
important Darwinian evolution
that takes place,
which is to say that the
syphilis of the fifteenth and
sixteenth centuries is quite
different from syphilis
thereafter.
Syphilis in its first century
or so was what we might call the
"Great Pox,"
a disease that was much more
severe than modern syphilis.
So, syphilis clearly begins as
a dreadful epidemic that swept
Europe and then the world.
After the sixteenth century,
it's still a very serious
illness, but it's much milder,
less fatal and less agonizing.
Today we're going to deal
primarily with the early
syphilis, the syphilis of the
Great Pox.
Now, the mode of transmission
is clearly important,
and we need to examine what are
the particular features of STDs,
of sexually transmitted
diseases.
Among the venereal diseases--to
use an older term--
syphilis was king from the
fifteenth century until the late
twentieth,
when there was the appearance
of a much more threatening
competitor,
HIV/AIDS.
And in more recent times,
after World War II and the
introduction of the era of
antibiotics--
particularly penicillin--and
sex education,
there's been a radical decline
in the incidence of syphilis.
And for a time there were even
heady hopes that it could be
eradicated altogether.
But most recently,
unfortunately,
it's made something of a
comeback.
Now, keep in mind,
too, that historically the STDs
weren't carefully distinguished,
one from another.
Until late in the nineteenth
century, other significant
STDs--gonorrhea and chancre,
in particular--weren't known to
be separate diseases.
They were thought to be simply
milder manifestations of
syphilis.
So, there was,
we might say,
a unicity theory of the
venereal diseases;
there was thought to be one
disease.
A reason for dealing with
syphilis now,
at this point in the course,
is that it had a significant
impact on medical science,
in ways that we've already
touched upon with regard to
bubonic plague.
That is to say,
like plague,
syphilis seemed clearly to be
contagious,
and it was understood,
from the beginning,
to be spread somehow--no one
quite knew how--
through sexual contact.
And, so, like plague,
syphilis challenged the
reigning orthodoxy of
humoralism,
and gave rise through someone
we've already met,
and we can look at again in a
moment,
through Girolamo Fracastoro,
in particular,
to the doctrine of contagion.
And it generated also the idea
that disease might be a specific
entity.
Syphilis was clearly something
distinctive, and many people
regarded it as a disease on its
own, rather than an example of
humoral imbalance.
So, syphilis had an impact on
medical science and influenced,
along with plague the--if we
like, began to make humoral
doctrine less stable at its
foundations.
Well, where does syphilis come
from?
What are its origins?
And here there's a major
debate, that has not been
resolved, and it continues down
to this day.
I'll put forward a couple of
candidates.
And I think it's more important
to note these different origins,
theories of the origins of
syphilis,
because they have a big impact
on how the disease is
experienced.
Rather than expecting us to
resolve the issue of where the
disease came from in fact,
let's note how people thought
the disease appeared.
A first theory was the one
associated with Christopher
Columbus.
This is the Americanist idea of
the origins of syphilis.
And we've talked already about
the Columbian Exchange.
So, I just wanted to review
that again.
That's Columbus's first trip,
and this is the idea of the
Columbian Exchange,
of what was transmitted from
the Old World to the New,
the Old World contributing
various foodstuffs,
like coffee beans and rice,
livestock--
cows--and various diseases;
as you already know,
smallpox, measles and so on,
and the New World being the
source for Europeans of corn,
potatoes and so on,
certain precious metals,
tobacco.
And there is the idea that the
Americanists--so called--argued
that it was Columbus and his
crew who brought back syphilis
from the New World.
This idea held that syphilis
was endemic in the New World,
spread to Columbus's sailors,
and was reported to Europe on
their return.
The problem,
of course, for the theory,
is that there isn't,
in fact, any definitive
evidence that syphilis did exist
in the New World at the time,
or that Columbus's sailors were
actually infected in the manner
required by the theory.
So, the evidence in support of
this is entirely circumstantial.
The chronology works.
That's one factor.
And another is that there
isn't, in fact,
in the medical literature,
before this time a disease like
syphilis anywhere in Europe.
And more recently,
paleopathologists haven't
unearthed evidence of syphilis
in European cemeteries.
It clearly seems to be a
disease that was a new--or let
us use an anachronistic term--an
emerging disease in the 1490s.
And because of Eurocentrism,
and perhaps xenophobia,
there was a preference to blame
the other.
A second idea that was very
popular was that syphilis,
instead of being of American or
New World origins,
was of Spanish or African
origin.
This theory held that perhaps
the disease was present in
Europe for a long time,
but had been confined to a
small corner of the continent,
perhaps--and one can see
certain sinister views here--
confined perhaps to Jews,
or Moors in Spain,
and unnoticed by outsiders.
Then with the expulsion of the
Jews in the 1490s,
the disease was disseminated
across Europe.
Now, among those who propounded
this view, there was clearly a
current of racism,
anti-Semitism and xenophobia.
Syphilis was supposed to have
been endemic among the Jews,
having come perhaps earlier
from Africa,
and was prevalent in those
populations because their sex in
some way was unnatural and out
of control.
So, syphilis was confined in
Europe to Spain,
this theory argues,
until the expulsion of the Jews
in 1492,
when they unleashed their
contagion on the rest of Europe.
In any case,
what's really clear is that
absolutely no one wanted to
acknowledge syphilis as his or
her own.
For Italians,
syphilis was somebody else's,
it was the French disease.
For the French,
it was the Neapolitan disease.
For Russians,
it was the Polish disease.
And for everyone,
it was the Great Pox,
or the clap.
Now, how do we get the term
syphilis, where does that come
from?
The word itself was coined by
the Italian physician,
whom you've already met,
Fracastoro,
who did something extraordinary
in 1531,
which was that he wrote a work
called Syphilis.
And here was Fracastoro,
whose face you've seen again.
Now, this work was odd,
or unusual, in a number of
respects.
It was a poem,
written in Latin,
and modeled on Virgil.
And, as I think about it,
I can't think at the moment of
another poem about an epidemic
disease.
It was also an instant success.
It rapidly went through lots of
editions, and established
Fracastoro's fame,
even more than his more
scientific works.
It also offered what I think we
could say was a clearly
moralizing, judgmental analysis
of this disease as a scourge of
God.
You know the drill by now.
In the poem,
the first victim of the disease
was a shepherd whose name was
Syphilis.
And the shepherd had offended
the gods by turning against them
and worshipping a king as a
deity.
So, in their anger,
the gods afflicted Syphilis
with this terrible pox.
We can see that built into it,
from the beginning,
was the idea that syphilis was
best understood as the wages of
sin.
And there's a further polemical
thrust that's not made explicit
but is a subtle undertow in the
poem.
Remember, the poem was written
in the 1530s,
in the midst of a religious
schism with Martin Luther,
a devout adherent of
orthodoxy--that is,
Fracastoro was--and of the
Catholic Church.
He was a physician to bishops,
archbishops and cardinals.
And Syphilis,
as I've said,
was a shepherd,
and in Latin the word for
shepherd is
pastor.
The man who was punished was a
pastor, not a priest;
that is, possibly a Protestant
leader.
So, there's a sly hint here
that syphilis,
the disease,
is a divine punishment for the
Reformation.
So, Fracastoro didn't adhere to
the Americanist position.
Then there's perhaps a third
more modern idea,
or hypothesis,
is that perhaps the causative
agent of syphilis emerged in a
Darwinian manner;
the spirochete or treponema
pallidum,
arose perhaps as a mutation of
some pre-existing treponemes
that are morphologically very
similar under the microscope,
and perhaps it was--it emerged
as an evolution from the
treponeme that causes yaws.
In any case,
it was clear that whatever the
site of its origin,
it spread across Europe with
terrifying rapidity.
One can see the role of
warfare, in particular,
in promoting the movement of
syphilis.
And its spread across Europe
was closely associated with
Charles VIII of France,
known as Charles the Affable,
who lived from 1470 to '98,
and launched a series of wars
with Italy,
which he invaded in 1494,
at the head of a large,
large army.
The army marched across the
Italian Peninsula and reached
Naples, that Charles besieged
and captured.
He then found himself facing a
powerful coalition of powers
that have ultimately defeated
him.
And after his forced
withdrawal--the point is that
his army disbanded.
And this was a large army,
a mercenary force of tens of
thousands of men from various
nationalities.
A feature of war is that it's
always a providential time for
epidemic disease,
and sexually transmitted
diseases in particular.
The army of Charles VIII was
poorly disciplined.
It indulged in pillage,
plunder and rape,
and it had its numerous camp
followers of beggars and
prostitutes.
So, among the troops,
and those who consorted with
them, the disease flared up.
And after their disbanding and
demobilization,
it was disseminated across the
continent.
Between 1495 and 1520,
something frightful happened as
the epidemic swept Europe from
Naples to Moscow;
to Oslo, Madrid,
London, and every place in
between.
So, this is the origin of
syphilis.
However it arose--whether it
was imported,
whether it was a newly emerging
disease,
perhaps a mutation from yaws,
from a disease already present
in Europe--
it was clearly spread by this
favorable opportunity of warfare
and the army of Charles VIII.
Well, what's the etiology and
symptomatology of syphilis?
And here, this is the causative
agent, the treponema
pallidum,
or spirochete.
This, the treponema
pallidum,
has a special feature,
in that it's exquisitely
fastidious and fragile,
and re quires very precise
conditions in order to live.
It cannot survive outside of
bodily fluids and the warmth of
the human body,
and therefore it can only be
transmitted by intimate contact.
Indeed, the spirochete is so
delicate that it can hardly be
cultivated in vitro,
and that's one of the reasons
that the development of a
vaccine has proved so difficult.
Well, there's an initial
incubation period with syphilis,
and we'll talk about three
stages in its impact on the
individual human body.
The first stage--and we're
talking now about the Great Pox,
this early stage in the history
of syphilis--
the first stage lasted a month
or two,
and was marked by a painful and
alarming chancre at the site of
entry of the spirochete into the
body.
But this chancre heals
spontaneously,
just like lesions in chickenpox
or herpes.
But that doesn't mean that the
patient is cured.
The disease in fact persists,
but for a time without
generating symptoms.
Then there's the onset of the
second stage of syphilis,
between forty-five days after
the disappearance of the chancre
and a year.
There are numerous symptoms,
but in the second stage of
syphilis only the superficial
tissues of the skin are
affected, with rash and boils.
Now, it was this second stage
of syphilis that was of
extraordinary severity during
the era of the Great Pox.
It was painful,
disfiguring,
incapacitating and often fatal.
There were sores and swellings
all over the body,
from the soles of the foot to
the crown of the head,
leaving disfiguring scabs and
pockmarks.
Worse, the disease was
described as attacking the whole
of the body.
It was said to eat it away and
consume it.
The body stank,
and the sufferers were
afflicted,
in addition,
with fever and pain in their
joints,
so intense, one contemporary
wrote,
that the victims screamed day
and night,
envying the very dead.
Let's listen to Fracastoro
himself, who described the Great
Pox like this.
He wrote--remember,
he was a physician as well as a
poet--"In the majority of
cases, small ulcers began to
appear on the sexual organs.
They were intractable and would
not depart.
Next, the skin broke out with
encrusted pustules.
They soon grew,
little by little,
until they were the size of an
acorn;
which they in fact resembled.
Then these ulcerated pustules
ate away the skin and sometimes
infected not only the fleshy
parts, but the very bones as
well.
In cases where the malady was
firmly established,
in the upper parts of the body,
the patient suffered from
pernicious catarrh that eroded
the palate,
or the pharynx and tonsils.
In some cases the lips,
the nose and eyes were eaten
away, or in others,
the whole of the sexual organs.
Moreover, many patients
suffered from the great
deformity, or gummata
that developed.
Besides all of the above
symptoms, as if they were not
bad enough, violent pains
attacked the muscles.
These pains were persistent,
tormented the sufferer chiefly
at night, and were the most
cruel of all the symptoms."
There is a theory that maybe
even the disease was too
virulent for its own good,
that its symptoms were so
debilitating as to prevent
sufferers from transmitting it,
and so the modern disease
evolved during the sixteenth and
seventeenth centuries as a
milder form of the Great Pox.
I'll show you a couple of
images of extreme forms of
modern syphilis,
that's said to give us some
idea of what the Great Pox was
like.
They're rather,
of course, unpleasant slides.
So, I would tell you that in
advance.
But this will give you some
idea of how terrible the Great
Pox was.
It looked like that,
or indeed like that.
We'll move on.
Then there's third-stage
syphilis, tertiary syphilis,
and in this phase you have
involvement of the deep tissues.
And its symptoms are things
such as what's called tabes
dorsalis,
which is a degeneration of the
neurons in the spinal cord,
and leads therefore to lack of
coordination,
to a stumbling gait,
and symptoms of that kind;
to ataxia, which means the
stumbling gait.
It also leads,
in this phase,
to cardiovascular disease,
often to insanity and dementia,
to general paralysis,
and to death.
So, tertiary syphilis can be
the cause of death.
What were--if that's what the
disease looked like--what were
some of its effects on society?
Well, because of its mode of
transmission,
syphilis was associated with
terrible social effects,
with anxiety,
guilt, pain,
broken relationships,
breakdowns in trust within
families,
infertility among women.
And like the plague,
and unlike some of the diseases
that we'll be studying,
syphilis was no respecter of
persons, of social class or
status.
We might perhaps ironically
call it a democratic disease,
in that it afflicted everyone,
from the bottom of the social
scale,
to aristocrats,
learned professionals,
kings, cardinals,
bishops, occasionally even
popes,
such as Julius II,
who was also a syphilitic.
So, accordingly,
one might argue,
syphilis caused a great strain
on society,
but not along the fissures
running between classes,
as did, for example,
Asiatic cholera.
It was also unlike plague in
that it was not terrifyingly
swift, and its obvious
association with sex meant that
the means to avoid it were
clear.
And so there was no generalized
terror, of the kind that
accompanied say bubonic plague
or Asiatic cholera.
Everyone knew how syphilis
could be avoided.
What were the effects on then?
One was a new asceticism.
There was a suspicion of
pleasures.
In the Protestant world,
an epidemic of syphilis was
perfectly timed not to create--
and here I don't want to be
saying that epidemic diseases
created Puritanism;
I would argue instead simply
that this is a disease that
reinforced it.
Asceticism indeed had long been
present in European culture,
but syphilis helped make it
more popular and a widely held
sentiment.
In the Catholic world,
one can see a new piety as
well, in the Catholic
Reformation, in Jansenism,
for example.
Another impact clearly was in
terms of tensions between the
sexes.
Now, this is familiar to you;
we're going back over old
ground in our course.
Remember paintings that we saw
earlier of the Garden of Eden
and Origin Sin,
Adam drawn into evil by his
helpmate Eve,
the original temptress.
Well, the passage of syphilis
was marked by a sinister
undertow of misogyny.
In a patriarchal society,
male fears,
anxieties, and indeed guilt,
were projected onto women,
who were seen as the crucial
agents in the spread of this
disease to men.
And two groups of women were
particularly suspect,
prostitutes first.
And here was a prime example of
a new male double standard.
The passage of syphilis was
marked by harsh police measures
against prostitutes,
including the closing of
brothels and the rounding up and
exile of people from
communities.
There was also a hunt for
scapegoats, and witch hunts were
part of that.
Another feature was a new
religious cult;
the cult, in particular,
of a new saint.
And this is rather unique,
which is there's only,
as far as I know,
one saint who wasn't a
Christian,
and this is Job,
from the Book of Job in the Old
Testament.
Job, however,
was actually said--in the Book
of Job, he had an especially
convincing defense attorney,
and that was God himself.
Because God says in the Book of
Job that this is the most just
of all men, he's the best and
most innocent.
And yet to try his faith,
he was scourged by Satan.
This is a painting by William
Blake of this scourging of Job
by Satan, who's pouring out
boils that will soon torment him
from head to foot.
And the description of the
disease that afflicted Job,
in the Book of Job,
is highly suggestive of what we
might call a venereal disease or
STD.
He was covered from head to
foot in boils.
And yet Job was reassuringly
free from sin.
We know that because God tells
us so.
And, so, Job became the patron
saint of syphilitics.
There was also a public health
response;
that is to say,
the building of hospitals for
the incurables,
who were the syphilitics.
And there was a new
philanthropy,
and religious orders that took
over their care.
Let's look for a moment at some
of the treatment regimens that
were also important in this
disease.
One was the beginning--it
began, the most common treatment
regimen,
with a forty-day period,
beginning with fasting,
and then the administration of
mercury,
which had been used in the
treatment of skin disorders over
the centuries,
diseases such as scabies.
So, mercury was sometimes
applied--it was applied in lots
of different ways.
Disparate remedies for a
desperate disease.
Ointments were applied to the
skin lesions.
There was a so-called general
friction in which applications
of mercury were made to the
whole body.
Sometimes it was administered
internally.
But as you know,
mercury is extremely toxic.
It causes great salivation,
the falling out of the teeth,
and then serious and often
life-threatening symptoms.
But salivation seemed to be the
right approach.
According to humoralist
principles, it would lead to an
evacuation of the peccant humor.
And it also--and here was a
factor--
it seemed to work when applied
to second-stage syphilis,
perhaps simply because,
as we've already seen,
second-stage syphilis goes into
spontaneous and often lengthy
remission.
And it was possible to argue
that it was the therapy,
the treatment,
that had been effective.
And perhaps the suffering that
accompanied this particular
treatment provided some moral
satisfaction to those who
administered it.
Another remedy that was tried
was guaiac, which is a hardwood
from a tree in the New World.
It was ground into sawdust and
made into a decoction that
patients drank twice a day for
forty days.
We see these forty days
appearing over and over:
in quarantine;
the forty day fasting;
the regimen for mercury;
the regimen for guaiac.
Well, all of this,
of course, had a religious
background.
And, so, the guaiac was
administered for forty days,
during which there was fasting.
At the same time then--so
guaiac and mercury were,
so we might say,
the miracle drugs,
the wonder drugs of their era.
There were other indications
also recommended for syphilis:
bloodletting,
baths, purgation,
cauterization of the boils.
An important impact,
then--the next thing I want to
point out--is the impact of
syphilis on medical science.
We already--and this gives us a
moment of review--we know
already the traditional approach
to these and other diseases;
that they were an imbalance of
humors.
There had been no idea of
discrete entities that were
diseases.
Diseases were an individual
matter, depending on the
constitution of the patient and
the environmental influences
that acted on him or her.
In the nineteenth century,
however,
we've seen already that
diseases fully crystallized into
forms of specific entities,
that were actually biological
entities that existed apart from
the body of the individual
sufferer.
The period from the 1490s to
the nineteenth century,
the period that emplaced both
plague and the Great Pox,
and then modern syphilis,
marked an era of transition.
And I would argue that syphilis
was something that propelled
this transition forward.
Remember how traditional
medicine, as taught at
universities and practiced by
the elite physicians,
was that the truth about
disease was to read the
classics: Hippocrates and Galen,
supplemented later,
in the Middle Ages,
by astrology.
So, for humoralist physicians,
then,
that was the way it was
preceded, and when syphilis
first struck,
there were disputations in
which people sought the truth of
the disease by looking through
into Hippocrates,
or what Galen had written.
And so there were disputes,
disputations that were formally
held through library medicine.
The challenge of syphilis was
that it was a pandemic that was
difficult to explain within the
traditional framework of
humoralism.
At the same time,
the disease had no real place
in the Classics.
Humoralism was static,
and had no way of accommodating
emerging diseases.
So, what do you do with a
disease that was unknown to the
Ancients?
Syphilis was also clearly
contagious,
everyone could see that,
and so there was obviously some
morbific substance that passed
from one body to another.
The disease,
in other words,
seemed to be something
specific;
and this helped to promote also
the idea of a new concept of
disease.
And syphilis tried physicians
because it really was an
incurable disease at the time,
and until the late twentieth
century didn't respond to the
classical recommendations for
therapy.
All of this made it a major
challenge to humoralist
orthodoxy.
And with that,
I would say we've reviewed this
period of syphilis and plague
that presented a major impact on
society,
and a major impact on medical
science.
And we've run out of time this
morning.
Next time, having had our
review session,
we'll come back to the
nineteenth century and deal with
the debate,
the huge medical debate,
between contagionists and
anti-contagionists.